hey guys it's max and vadim and today we
are doing another blind camera
comparison that you guys love we're
taking a look at the new iphone SE and
we're comparing it to the 10r in the 11
in keep in mind the 10r has the same
camera as the 10s and 11 has the same
camera as my $1100 iPhone 11 pro max yep
and the cool thing about this video is
that we're actually both doing this
unbiased test because we had Angelica
put these photos together so neither of
us know which ones which now yeah we
both have our tally sheets and we
recommend you guys grab one of these and
do this test along with us let's go
ahead and find out if we can tell the
difference between the spore
hundred-dollar phone with iPhone 8
sensors inside and these higher end more
expensive phones here is the first image
here which one do you think looks the
best to you so I was actually looking at
this a little bit because it's the first
photo and to me it's the one on the left
the one in the center it's just kind of
like the dynamic range just isn't there
especially in that shed and between the
left and the right I like how the inside
I guess is brighter than the one on the
right so I'm going with the left and I
actually have to vote differently these
two are almost identical we could see
that the middle one definitely has less
dynamic range it's all blown out I just
liked a little bit extra the saturation
all right and I have no idea oh oh no
way what wait a minute yes my Elevens
just the clap I chose the se10 R it was
that much worse yeah I was not expecting
this and the 10 R has larger sensors
that are no worse
the actual cameras are better what it's
the a13 that's in the SD that is doing
this now on to the next scene I think
I'm between the center and the right I
think I'm seeing more detail on the one
on the right and for me these are so
close obviously the duck moved here but
I could tell that there's a color
difference here to me these look more
similar and with the with white balance
compared to this one I'm gonna choose
the iPhone 11 again and I think this is
the iPhone 11 it's a little bit sharper
yes all right so what I'm seeing in this
one is that it's just crazy how similar
these are especially the one on the on
the left and in the center they're like
almost indistinguishable and the one on
the right you can tell that it's maybe
not as saturated or it's a little bit
cooler on the white balance I think I
actually prefer the one on the right it
just looks more clean to me I do as well
I like that the white looks a little bit
more white yeah and it looks like it's
slightly more detailed yeah 10 are
perfect
did not expect that I want to point out
I did take another shot the 11 is the
only one I could do portrait mode a
bunch of objects and it doesn't look
that great here but it can do it it
could do it in some cases it's nice so
this is a portrait mode shot with all of
them alright so between this I think I'm
going for the center because the one on
the right looks to have some sort of
kind of haze from the Sun and the one on
the left just looks like it has a little
bit of noise so I'm gonna go with the
center I'm gonna go with the one on the
left are you okay yes I'm scoring good I
deserve my eleven so these two looks so
similar to me the white balance looks
the same this actually a tough dynamic
range shot it was really dark here the
one on the left looks let's looks cooler
I think this looks more realistic but I
think I like that one the best DUI
honestly I'm gonna go with the one on
the very right I don't know for some
reason I just it looks more crisp it
looks sharper yeah you're right can I
can I change my mind I don't know you I
don't know about you but I'm going with
I'm changing my mind you I'm going on
there right so this one is a macro shot
because all of them are blurred out in
the background in I instantly notice
that the one on the Left doesn't look as
good it's just not as sharp but between
the center and the right I'm seeing more
detail in a more crisp looking image and
I'm seeing more dynamic range in the
fibers of that whatever that hair a
little flower yeah it's a little blown
out over here where this maintains all
the detail I'm voting
for this one as well it's also it can
get closer than these other two what Wow
that's my first se point what how it
does it get closer maybe just the sensor
is smaller and it allows it to get
closer I don't know but like for $400
man it's clearly the best one there to
be honest it is hard to tell a
difference here I'm voting for the
middle just cuz I haven't voted for the
middle for a while okay that one looks a
little darker though I don't know how
the white balance was in real life but
the one on the right just looks too cool
but the one on the left it looks like
everything kind of blends together like
the color of the water and the the
landscape right here just kind of blends
in so I'm also going for the center
Apple this is madness we thought we got
upgrades over the years
here this one is too cool this one's too
warm I like the extra contrast and looks
like it might be a little sharper I'm
voting for the right one yeah I do see
more detail in the trees and all the
texture everywhere on the right I'm
going with that 1 to 10 are what guys we
did not expect this for this one I'm
going for the center I already know what
it is I like the wider shot but not only
that look at my face is nice and bright
everything's exposed well here we're
blowing out more of the clouds and this
is all darker and this was this actually
looks very similar this shot just you
even even though it's a wider shot
you still get more detail on your vest
yeah then on the other - yeah 11 I see
yeah surprising so here with the dynamic
range the front camera it definitely
looks worse than the SE now this shot
here is a zoom shot so the 10 are in the
11 they don't have telephoto lenses 5
times zoom I'm gonna have to vote for
the one on the left it just looks more
more detailed these look kind of similar
this one kind of stands out to me yeah
so the one in the center is lacking
detail looks slightly blurry and the one
on the right looks like it has over
sharpening I don't know why compared to
the
laughs this one looks more natural left
as well Sumeet we actually have some
daylight coming in from the left hand
side and warm light from the top yeah I
would say this one is the sharpest this
one looks really good too really close
it's just not as close of a shot
this one looks the worst yeah the one on
the right I see more detail and
especially if I look at this place man
or whatever right there so right as well
I see wow what in the eleven also very
detailed this one just looks the were
specially over there this is a selfie
shot of me I have to go for the middle I
like it dynamic range here here my face
just glitz kind of darker and I'm seeing
a little bit more detail here so and
this is weird right here everything just
smeared all this color
you lose color detail I'm actually gonna
go with the left so I see more detail in
your shirt and the fibers of your shirts
but not the face I think your beard has
more detail to s/e
and I chose 11 the 10 are definitely for
the yes like the selfie camera on the 10
are it's not worse okay so for this one
we are not gonna vote because there is
obviously a difference here the 11 has
that ultra wide so we had this really
cool looking shot you see the hotel of
the building instead of this kind of
shot where I can go back anymore here so
we're not voting on it but the 11
definitely has that advantage and this
is a lower light shot not super low
light but kind of medium low light so so
easy that one yeah so without more
detail is that this is deep fusion it
has to be diffusion this is what I was
trying to test if diffusion worked
obviously this really stands out
exposure sharpness yeah well now that
texture and the lines of the yep okay
now what about between these two that's
kind of tough man this is kind of tough
I think the one in the center if you
look at the texture of the yeah a nano
and the text right here we have more
detailed okay so obviously we're voting
for this elaborate 11 but that S II does
look more detailed than the 10 are now
this is another low-light scenario not
super dark but it is dark this one
definitely looks the best to me this one
looks the worst I just see
more detail more color less noise less
compression artifacts here yeah it's
easy to tell that the one in the center
is just so much worse than the others
but between the left and the right it's
really tough like in this panel right
here of the wood I see more detail but
then their faces and everything else
looks better on the right but I'm yeah
I'm going to the right Wow very
interesting 10r doesn't have diffusion I
like the color the pop more and I like
the skin tones more the 11 does have
more detail here and here but that's not
what you care about an image like this
you care about the people look yeah I
don't know why you know you could tell
now that I think about it you could tell
that deep fusion is working you're
getting more detailed but I think the
reason I chose the right one was because
you are getting some noise up here yeah
that's what I noticed because you don't
really get that noise I just liked how
my kids look better in the photo s.e
it's crazy in this little light
situation it's better bein I don't know
if it's smeared a little bit or what
definitely the worst now this shot is a
front-facing portrait mode shot super
dark outside I did use the flash as well
and as you guys can see the center one I
tested it many times the portrait mode
just wouldn't work even though it was
enabled it wouldn't work so which one
are you choosing I'm choosing the one on
the right I mean if I was choosing an
image that I would keep it would be the
center still so 11 on the right 10 our
portrait doesn't work but it does not
look we agree that doesn't look good
se looks nice and sharp a portrait just
didn't work yeah and I think this is the
last shot here if you know phones you
probably know what's going on
this one has night mode in the middle
yeah you could see the difference here
yeah Center of course it's got night
mode okay 11 obviously has that and the
SE looks better than the 10r with the
worst sensor yeah I think that is the
last image so what did you get Medivh so
I got five for the SE I have seven for
the 10r and only four for the iPhone 11
Wow
I don't know how that happened but like
honestly I we should move back to that
I'm not going to
I have two for the se6 for the 10r and I
have eight for the eleven now this
doesn't really tell the whole story
in a couple of ways first off and a lot
of cases the SE beat out the 10r I think
a different one I gave ratings when I
knew which ones were which and that
helped kind of even it out in a lot of
cases the SE beat the 10r but in some
cases ten are slightly beat out the
eleven and we were surprised and then of
course the eleven does have the extra
ultra-wide lens and it has a night mode
so it definitely takes the lead there
but overall I was really surprised I was
surprised how the S II yeah beat out the
ten are in a lot of cases and I was also
surprised out the ten are beat out the
eleven in some cases yeah I think the
ten are does a really good job for
bright environments maybe it's the
larger sensor that does that and I don't
know how it was beating out the iPhone
11 in those situations but for me
yeah but then when there's dynamic range
or lower light you dynamic range the
other two in lower light the other two
when so overall the se for 400 bucks is
doing a dang good job unless you're in
that medium lighting cousin super low
light it does better but that medium low
light the suffer is a little bit other
than that it does a great job so give us
your thoughts and your opinions down in
the comment section below you guys want
to see how the se compares to the pixel
3a we'll have a video over there on that
side and make sure you guys click that
circle above to subscribe this man max
and Vadim and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]